-We're so excited to welcome
our first guest
back to the show.
He's an Emmy-nominated comedian
who is currently on tour.
For information
on his upcoming shows,
go to tracymorgan.com/tour.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
the one the only
Tracy Morgan, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, T!
-Yo, yo.
It's always good
to be back, man.
-How have your last five --
-You know, I know Greg, right?
-You know Craig, the drummer?
-Me and Greg go back like
spinal cords and car seats.
-Okay, great.
Now, you're calling him --
You're calling him Greg --
You're calling him Greg,
and his name is Craig,
so that makes me doubt --
-I know!
Everybody else calls him Greg.
-Everybody calls him Greg.
-Same soup. Same soup,
just a different bowl.
-[ Laughs ] Okay, great.
Now, quick, you've been gone
for five months.
I haven't seen you.
-Everybody's been gone
for five months.
I ain't seen you either.
-Now we're back.
What have you been up to?
-I ended the strike.
Thank you.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-That was me.
-That was you?
-You ended the strike?
-I ended the strike.
-How?
-Between the Writers Guild
and the studios.
I went into the meeting with two
of my trusted negotiators --
Craig O. and Bobby Bats.
[ Laughter ]
And I told them,
"If you don't end the strike,
you're going to have
to deal with them."
-Oh, wow.
-Strike was over.
-Hey, well, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean...
-Now we are back. We are back.
-But, you know, I know
you're a New Yorker
through and through.
A very harrowing week
with the flooding.
Were you caught up on Friday?
-No, I was on the West Coast.
I was doing some shows
on the West Coast,
but I heard about the storm.
-Yeah.
-I heard about the rain,
and I heard that one of
the sea lions escaped
from Central Park.
-Yep.
-He escaped from Central Park
and he swam downtown.
-Okay. Really?
-But he saw
the size of the rats,
and he was disgusted,
so he just jumped in an Uber
and came on back uptown.
-He did? Oh.
Oh, well, that's nice.
I'm glad that he's back.
You haven't --
You were on the West Coast.
You've been doing
a lot of traveling.
-Yeah, been doing traveling.
I love it.
-You love being on the road?
-Having a bunch of fun.
I love being on the road.
You know?
Stand up is my foundation.
-Yeah.
-So I love being -- going --
me and my cousin.
My cousin is with me, Lavelle.
He's with me.
His name is Lavelle,
but his real name is Anthony.
-Okay.
-I call him by his --
I don't call him by
his "government."
He calls his real name
So we go through the airport.
You know, the TSA.
-Yeah.
-Security.
And when you stay
on the yellow line
and you got to put
your hands up like this.
-Yep.
-My cousin said,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know the position.
I've been doing this
since I was 14."
[ Laughter ]
-Now, it's very confusing.
If somebody
has two names like that,
that's when you get in trouble.
Do you worry about stuff
like identity theft?
Is that a thing...?
-I ain't worried about
no identity theft.
Not my family.
My family hopes somebody
steal our identity.
[ Laughter ]
They want to see
how a thief is going to do
with a 350 credit score
and tax problems.
They want to see exactly
how he going to do.
-Oh, so they might hope
somebody steals it
so they could give instruction
on how to deal with the fina--
Yeah, I see.
-Yeah.
-What about, you know, this is
a big issue in the strike
and continues to be
for SAG-AFTRA.
And I know you're
a member of that.
AI -- Are you --
are you concerned about AI?
-Man, I don't know
nothing about no technology.
-Okay.
-I don't even know
how to turn a computer off.
If it starts making noise,
I just pull the plug
out the wall.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. So I guess you're not
really at the AI level.
-I'm an old school, bro!
-[ Laughs ]
-All I do is karate
and make babies.
That's all I do.
In that order.
-That is...
Those are two wonderful hobbies.
Now, I also know
you're single now.
-Well, yeah. Yeah, I'm --
[ Audience oohs ]
Ladies, I'm on -- I'm on Tinder.
[ Laughter ]
My Tinder profile is
a Walmart truck
dropping off a bag of money
on my front lawn.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I'm dating again,
you know.
But you know, me,
I'm messing with the migrants.
That's my thing.
I mess with migrants
'cause it ain't about money.
It's about the green card.
-Oh, interesting.
-You don't even
got to have a rap.
Or you got to do
is walk up to them and say,
"You want to stay here?"
-Wow.
-"America's nice, right?
Yeah. Bring your scooter."
But she got -- But she got
to have a dark tooth.
-A dark tooth?
-I look dark tooth.
That's my style.
-Just...Just the --
-One dark tooth.
Okay.
So, that's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
Do you ever worry when you see
that on someone's dating profile
that they've used a filter
to darken one tooth
for the purposes of...?
-Yeah, but I can see
through that.
-Yeah, you can
see through that.
You -- I've heard you mention
there was that very...
that brawl.
-Oh, yeah.
-It was -- Was it --
It was a riverboat.
-Yeah. I started it.
-You did?
-You talking about
the brawl in Alabama?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The riverboat.
-I started that. I started that.
-You started that?
So you ended the strike
and you started that.
-The brawl.
-How'd you start the brawl?
-I parked my boat there.
-Uh-huh.
-Then this other dude said,
"Hey, can I park my boat here?"
I said, "Sure. What's the worst
that can happen?"
Then I went and got me
a fish "sammich,"
and I came back
and it was WrestleMania.
-[ Laughs ] No!
So, let me get this straight.
You go off to get
a fish sandwich.
-Sammich!
-Okay. Sorry.
-I say sammich.
-You got a fish sammich.
-I'm from the ghetto.
-Yes. You get a fish sammich.
-Yeah.
-And then when you come back,
it's just mayhem?
-It was WrestleMania.
-[ Laughs ]
-They was throwing down, bro.
-You went to -- You were at the
Giants game last night, right?
-I'm still hurting.
-Yeah. I'm sorry.
-Still traumatized.
-Yep.
I think maybe they should
get Rudy as quarterback.
-Rudy from the...?
-They didn't remember
the Titans!
-Do you think they should get --
you should get --
-Got to remember the Titans!
-But isn't -- isn't Rudy
from a different movie?
-You're trying to confuse me.
-Yeah.
Well, if you ever want
to keep it straight...
an easy way to remember is
Rudy's from
a movie called "Rudy."
[ Laughter ]
Tracy, I know you to be
an athlete, a former athlete.
-Yeah.
-And lest people
think I'm making light,
this is...
-They think I was born
into this body.
[ Indistinct ]
I'm illegitimate son
of Denzel Washington.
-You were a hurdler
in high school.
And that is no joke.
Hurdling is, you know,
one of the...
-Got to run through the hurdles.
-You've got to run through it.
But you did not
run through the hurdle.
Look at Tracy Morgan...
hurdling as a young man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were not messing around.
-No, I wasn't.
Those were my Carl Lewis days.
-Your Carl Lewis days.
And I remember I saw it
when I started at "SNL."
People said,
"Oh, you should go back
and you should watch Tracy
Morgan's audition for 'SNL,'"
because you auditioned,
one of your bits was a hurdler.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And you were --
you could still --
you could still
get your legs up.
It was very impressive.
-Yeah, that was a
long time ago, though.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I enjoyed watching it.
-Many surgeries ago.
-Many sur-- How is your...?
-[ Stammers ] My life...
I just believe that maybe
Tony Dorsett or Drew Pearson
are my biological father.
-Yeah.
Well, I don't know, 'cause
Tony used to drive a white van.
-[ Laughs ]
-He sold fish out
the back of that van.
-Right, right, right.
Did you -- How is your health?
You mentioned
all these surgeries.
-I'm good. I'm sweet.
I'm sweet like bear meat.
-You haven't had to go in...?
-I'm sweet like bear meat.
You see all the weight
I've lost, right?
-You look good.
-That's that Ozempic.
-You're on the Ozempic?
That's great. Do you like it?
-I bought my Ozempic
off the streets.
-Okay.
-That's the good stuff
on the street.
-Okay, so you're getting
street Ozempic.
-I'm on the streets.
I'm out there on them streets.
-You feel safe taking street
Ozempic?
-Yes!
-Tracy, as --
-Even though legalized weed,
I'm still going underground
to get mine
'cause that's where
the good stuff is!
It ain't been stepped on.
-Oh, they step on the Ozempic
you get from a doctor?
-In the hospital.
-Yeah. Okay.
-I know a dude named --
I know a dude named Doc.
-Doc?
-He's up in Harlem.
He's making Ozempic.
-Gotcha.
So the Doc, you know,
is not a medical professional.
-That's where I go get it.
I knock on the door.
"Let me get two Ozempic."
-[ Laughs ]
So you get your Ozempic two
at a time?
-On the streets.
-[ Laughs ]
Well, it's working.
You look like a million bucks.
-Sweet like bear meat.
You've got some upcoming dates.
I want to share
your upcoming dates.
I'm very excited. If you're
going to be in Atlantic City...
Come out. Come out. Come out.
-Ocean Casino Resort,
October 13th.
Foxwoods.
You're going to Foxwoods
on October 14th.
And for more upcoming
information on its tour dates,
go to tracymorgan.com/tour.
I love you, buddy. It's always
so good to have you here.
-I love you more.
-How about this?
How about Tracy Morgan?
[ Indistinct ]
We'll be right back
with Chris Hayes.